my hair looks so not weird today it's on
fleek that's what the cool kids say on
fleek it's freaky there you go nice this
is this is called sex appeal right here
I like it
hi guys I'm Greg you see that did the
whole thing yeah with the lovely Ashley
a nerd from the channel the taco of tal
ko hence flood kids who are a failure to
their parents I'm on this list cuz I'm a
celebrity yes
look right at me ma yeah yeah cool I'm
getting there ashley is from the channel
how to's with Morgan and Ashley her and
Morgan - lovely blonds teach you how did
you lots of fun things lots of fun
things exercise for you joking care for
you boys out there doing cocktails
cocktails dessert food baby adventures
Wow Wow yeah you should do a video
called how to satisfy a woman okay
I think Morgan would have a lot to say
about that I think so right more vocal
about it than you would levy our guests
for it oh yeah I would know all the
right we're gonna be all about you know
women pleasuring a guy that's how you
pleasure a woman anyway let's learn
about having failures this is gonna be
no it's four and a half minutes ten
we'll talk about the ones after that we
stand up and add to it it's not easy
living the shadow of the bright light
center always on your parents now that
these children of celebrities just
couldn't seem to fill their lives
together for the sake of their parents
if you are a first-time viewer click the
red subscribe button and give this video
a big thumbs up today we are discussing
pencil up kids who are still your person
right Jaden Smith
it's really talented even if father
blokes mescaline so another thing that
everyone knows is Jaden is truly out
there when it comes to his Twitter post
his Twitter pages sofas are that even as
dad can't come to this defense
well half admitted that when he told
Jaden about the freedom of expression he
may have gone too far
well think he's created a self
expressing monster and claims that Jaden
can be too much for even him to handle
it Wow Conrad Hilton the father of Paris
and Nicky Hilton Conrad Hilton has had
brushes with the law for years most
recently he had a meltdown on an
airplane that won immunity in jail while
on a flight from Los Angeles to London
the 20-something hotel air [ __ ] to
kill crew members and called fellow
passengers peasant
well encouraged and the altercation were
in violation of the probation helping
with sentence to three more years of
probation Rob and community service
Prince and Paris Jackson their father
was one of the most controversial and de
loved' celebrities on the planet but
Michael Jackson's kids prints in Paris
Jackson aren't really living up to their
famous last names not in videos on
social media then getting tattoos
tattoos themselves get a little
questionable
most recently Prince Jackson got a
tattoo riddled with missed clothes and
misspellings which has left many to
question what the heck was he thinking
Frances Bean Cobain considering her
father Kurt Cobain died when she was
just a little girl Frances Bean Cobain
has had a pretty rough life after she
registering relationship with her mother
and now it seems some other issues have
led to her divorce they are started the
divorce process in spring of 2016 but
the truth didn't come out until later
her ex claims she has a raging shopping
addiction as well as hoarding issues the
divorce has done one good thing for
Frances as her mother Courtney Love and
her are finally working on the
relationship Oh Nicolay a better known
as Nick Hogan started to share the
spotlight with his dad Hulk Hogan when
he appeared on the reality show hope he
knows best sadly things took a major
downward spiral after an accident in
2007 then at the age of 15 ballet was
involved in a street racing accident
that left his friend severe brain damage
and on medical support fully applied no
contest to reckless driving charge and
spent 166 days in jail remembering
Douglas the Douglas family is a
Hollywood legend like Cameron does this
is making a name for him
ompletely less-than-stellar ways the son
of Michael Douglas and grant and a Kirk
Douglas had battled with drugs in
addiction for years his addiction led
him to be arrested for possession of
meth and heroin being in prison didn't
even stop him
and he confessed that he smuggled and
distributed drugs in his facility while
Cameron was finally released from prison
in the fall of 2015 after serving seven
years montana fishburne the daughter of
laurence fishburne montana made
headlines in 2010 when she announced the
release of her sex tape being the often
deadly marshburn and friendly hide the
biotope copies of Montana's porn did you
support anyone to see Oh mommy he failed
and affected certain area I'm in great
pain and discipline and try to
understand why your daughter did the
tapes but eventually told her she is no
longer welcome in his life Wow we know
that Gordon being the son of the
greatest basketball player who ever
lived Michael Jordan can mean a lot of
pressure so much in fact that Marcus
Jordans every move seems to come under
the microscope but when he had a brush
with a loss of fighting two girls in a
parking lot he deserved to learn the
hard way to make matters more
embarrassing Marcus tweeted a picture of
his junk to all of his followers later
clean and rich hi JC Chen in 2014 fans
of Jackie Chan were shocked when his son
Jason Chen was arrested the Ben 31 year
old has tested positive for marijuana
and that have been hosting others to
also take drugs Jackie Chan was publicly
and privately distraught in a letter to
his fans on his website he apologized
and said he was enraged disappointed and
very sad about his son's action what Rob
Kardashian
over the years Rob Kardashian has been
seeking his mother and sisters at arm's
length
not only is he engaged to someone the
whole family hates but they had a baby
together in 2016 before the baby and
right before the Kimye wedding Rob and
his mother Kris Jenner got into an
alleged knock-down drag-out fight a Kris
went as far as to call Rob a fat failed
Softline loser since then it's been hard
for the family to pick up the pieces and
Men the mother and son strangulation
well do you think these two left hand
failures or not react in the comments
section below and don't forget to like
this
right for the taco I mean I wouldn't
call all them failures as well I mean I
think yeah and all of them it just
depends on like what the parents truly
do think
Will Smith doesn't seem to think it son
Jaden is a failure by any means no and
because their parents are so big it's
like they just expected it like they
should be yeah so that was my colossal
failure yes I mean some of them I'm like
I could kind of see the parents view
like Laurence Fishburne in his daughter
yeah sex safe yeah it seemed like he
that was pretty obvious that he was like
my daughter's a failure hey right not
because my daughter like that doesn't
seem like that big of us she got
divorced and they said the shillings
shopping addiction so she's just a [ __ ]
avoid Peter come on her dad died and
then she was so much like her mom she
does she does you look like your mom
thank you mm-hmm I'm love your mom let's
transfer to you she's not watching it I
hope you're watching I didn't know uh
montana fishburne did a sex tape I don't
know oddly who a lot of these kids are
like that's why they're failures at the
same time like the Hilton sign like
winds with the whole airplane thing yeah
I didn't even hear about that on like
the news or anything like that I think
Rob Hilton just have said that he's just
not as good-looking as the other Hilton
sisters you know me Mike to be the ugly
sibling guy must be tough that's why I
feel for my siblings you know I'm only
good looking for them out there watching
and they know they're bad
so nice and then the Rob Kardashian
while like I mean you can make your
doing Ethan Riley depends on show I
don't know the Kardashian you they all
seem like they're Apple love or hate
each other at any given moment if you
think they actually really are mad and
fists by analysts everything is just for
just for show yeah I think just for show
I feel like the Kardashians possess no
real emotion including Kim I feel like
me
I feel like they're just robots are
being told here's where you got to
pretend to feel right now I don't think
they have any real feeling towards each
other when the camera's not real it's
all business
mm-hmm the way I'm going to run my
family I don't care to be creative no
emotion yeah okay all right I just want
to
the reality show my family one day this
seems to be the easiest way to make
money Jaden Smith they follow him on
Twitter do you know these because like I
had I don't know about these no do you
know about these
no but I would love to see photos of him
kissing these are all on a like in
Instagram and Twitter right apparently
I'm the kids have a few hits he's in the
Karate Kid which is great yeah what did
the daughter there's a daughter too
right yeah she's like a did you know
anything I guess yeah yeah okay she like
did some scandalous things - right like
didn't she take pictures and like a fun
girl with a guy Kosovo I think so well
Will Smith went to jail when he was
younger
relief it was before Fresh Prince for
what I think he like beat up someone hmm
yeah look if is an [ __ ] that's what I
hear
putting that out there mr. apples Oh
actually levels I'm surprised with the
daughters not on this what's though -
well she's not failure she had a hit
album you know Gina Smith had like
Karate Kid and the percent happiness
which was all Will Smith's performance
which made that great I never watched
the Karate Kid - deal yeah he's really
good in it really yeah it's really good
yeah but you know it's had a lot of
failures outside of the Karate Kid all
right we'll look at through his Indiana
was funny when your movie after Earth's
with him Wolfman Wow my name is pretty
bad in that one I still think you could
kick my ass I like you watch his
reaction videos let's hope not I don't
think um the daddy didn't kids would be
considered a failure I was thinking too
because I feel like you far forgetting
and Michael Jackson was kind of wacko so
for attention to be lack of who is like
this is kind of normal compared to what
Michael Jackson was doing you know we're
not what does this tattoo say do not go
gentle in that good night rage rage
against the doing of the light wow
that's pretty deep they get a bad
Cobain's kid turned out pretty hot okay
yeah she's a that story success right
there the Hogan kid like crash the car
like almost dying yeah I mean these are
like Macy's kids me but I wouldn't call
these kid like failures and wife is now
I want to point out some of the
successes they've done the only one who
seems like they really failed was Kurt
Douglass's kid and Laurence Fishburne's
kid like bird their parents the Douglas
one was the drug one right yeah the one
who was like dealing drugs while in
prison oh yeah yeah that's pretty dark
yes that's really dark the winner of
yeah yeah yeah I want something yeah
it's hard to call phone of failures is
such a mean word I'd say like like
totally discredit anything they've ever
done you know my fella might look at me
and call me a failure but that everyone
knows it's not true
come on look at me I never call you that
great I only said that about you welcome
to confident Michael Jordan's kid what
are you doing here oh yeah he got in a
fight with two girls
oh yeah but see like we don't hear the
other side of that like maybe maybe they
were being mean to him maybe they were
trying to sexually assault entities
Michael Jordan's kid sounds like I'm a
[ __ ] efficient self we don't know yeah
you know that you know every time a man
is a woman sometimes it's a woman at all
no I'm learning a lot about you yeah
powers not video and a Jackie Chan son
hold on what this thing he like got
arrested for having pounds of marijuana
or something like that
okay the marijuana went like this Jackie
don't do that all the time right
yeah I mean I don't know yeah I got
pounds of marijuana on me right now
Jackie chanda seen him in interviews
yeah we're prior to this incident cuz I
grew up loving Jackie Chang he was one
of my heroes growing up Shanghai noon
yeah that was the one great movies good
we actually pitched John and I worked on
a concept for Shanghai dog I loved those
movies I think they're great David
they're calling should give you the okay
everything I done yeah Hollywood no we
have your approval no Jackie Chan talked
about how he doesn't feel like he's a
good father like he feels like he's very
neglectful he's even said work comes
first family second oh I've heard of sin
in a couple intertwining soid sounds of
failure I'm like you like it sounds like
a talented [ __ ] musician I know I put
[ __ ] in there a thousand musician a
thousand more emphasis there he's a
talented musician so what he got caught
with some weed and for Jackie Chan to be
like I am outraged devises come on
Jackie yeah me negative a parent can't
blame it all on him so what he likes to
smoke weed it feel better about the fact
that his father's neglectful should I
give you a moment on the personal or
this list Mississippi says failure to
their parents the only ones I see
Laurence Fishburne and the Douglas if I
had one more kid who would be another
kid you think it'd add to this list
that's not on the list
yeah hmm all these celebrities I'm sure
have like some really amazing is in some
not so great kids like how do you kids
make a list you know I don't know I
would say all of Brad Pitt and Angelina
Jolie his children are all failure I
wonder how they're gonna turn out to be
well the thing is it's like they've been
around for years they might not be
adults yet but they've been around for a
while man wasn't anything special all
the ours is drafted an anti-israeli kid
there are no buddies and then like what
about like Katie Holmes and Tom Cruise
is a very good series very I haven't got
the name of the high quality she's not
available I think those kids are failure
it will one of them's an adult
I think couple of them are failures you
don't live up to your parents potential
oh they're all failures oh thank God my
parents were famous
I've outdone them I don't agree with
anything he said that's all fact I don't
speak in sarcastic tones at all anyway
guys subscribe to the taco tal ko I just
feel like you know it's easy to get
confused you could like be able to type
in the real rejects put Rea
oh I mean he was really coming to
subscribe to the Arielle rejects if
you'd like Ashley is on the channel how
to's with Morgan and Ashley worth
fantastic how to do shits videos that's
our description how to finish it how the
P how to put on your underwear properly
what kind of socks you should wear when
you go out none of these are the raw
enhancing your boobs is enhancing a word
how to pronounce Morgan and Ashley great
personalities they're informative
because you know how to blonds make a
right I get it
cuz blonds have a reputation or being
kind of dumb mm-hmm but you guys are
doing it like how you know like two
wrongs make a right or two blondes oh
now I just got it Wow yeah do you guys
are smarter than your hair colors follow
them there yes how people on mega rate
check it check it check